can you feel that
they don't mention oh yeah
now remember Beto was the the one right
the the former punk rocker the rock star
who could turn it all blue in Texas
is the third time really the charm betta
O'Rourke hopes that it is is the name
recognition enough
for Texans to turn Texas blue for Beto
Democrats want to make inroads and
actually flip
um Texas from red to blue then they need
candidates like Bethel Aurora he's the
only one feeling blue these days because
a recent poll from the University of
Texas shows him down to Governor Greg
Abbott by 11 points but
it was something inside the pole that
really caught our eye and it speaks to
the reason we're here tonight now in his
2018 election win Governor Abbott lost
Hispanic voters by 11 points in that
University of Texas poll but he and Beto
are now tied at 48
amongst that slice of the electorate
huge ship joining us now Texas governor
Greg Abbott himself
great to be with you
now
that's a big shift I mean that's a
that's a double-digit shift for you
what's happening why is the Hispanics
coming to the Republican Party two
things one is we constantly reach out to
the Hispanic community no Governor has
gone down to the Rio Grande Valley more
than I have we're constantly reaching
out and connecting with the Hispanic
community and like your other guest
tonight the policies that I'm running on
are the policies that the Hispanic
community supports
they believe in hard work entrepreneurs
and hence they want to state that
creates jobs in a strong economy As We
Gather here tonight Texas has the
fastest growing economy of any state in
the United States also also Texas since
since these folks reelected me Texas has
added far more new jobs than any other
state in America Texas is the place for
Economic Opportunity but at the same
time Hispanics whether you're on the
border or in Houston Texas or north
Texas they don't want bidens or the
Democrats open border policies they want
a secure border and because Biden is not
doing it they have to have a governor
step up and secure the border and that's
exactly what I'm doing by taking
unprecedented action to build a wall to
deploy the National Guard to secure the
border and those who make it in we're
going to bust them up to Sanctuary
cities to New York Washington DC and
elsewhere okay
now
we want everyone to get out and vote
because I don't want people to feel
complacent like oh we got this no no
everybody's going to get out and vote
every American who's eligible to vote
has to get out there and vote and I want
to play Beto's pitch to mess MVC last
night Washington and or reduce
significantly gun violence in this state
especially when it comes to our kids
let's restore a woman's right to choose
let's get behind our public Educators
who are under attack and are leaving the
profession by the thousands the majority
of Texans are with us on this we're
going to have the political will to get
the job done
um he's anti-second amendment I mean
he'll talk a good game but he is against
gun rights in this state and across this
country is he not well let's use his
words he said he would confiscate your
guns so he wants to ignore the Second
Amendment to the United States
Constitution and take your guns well
he's also pushing the abortion issue
because the Democrats for a long time
thought that that was going to be their
Golden Goose here after the Dobbs
decision came down in June they thought
that was going to turn you know this
state blue and others like it on that
question how is Texas handling this
given all the Suburban women out there
who do have a different view on this
issue very different than in other
states on the abortion issue the recent
polling that showed I think in that same
poll that you made reference to it
showed who do you choose most on the
abortion issue or even among women and
so this is an issue where in Texas Texas
is a pro-life State what's going to have
here's here's
[Applause]
a second very importantly what everybody
in the state now knows because we've
exposed betcha on this issue Beto is in
favor not just of abortion but abortion
of a child to the very last second
before a fully developed child is born
and was even against providing medical
care for a baby who survives an abortion
that is horrible what Beto stands for so
he's the radical on the issue is your
claim Beto is the extremist on abortion
on the issue of ESG and what's happening
the um uh the equity agenda for
Corporate America and how the energy
industry which is so critical and vital
to this state is just under siege and
they're making a lot of money because
the the you know the quantity of oil and
so forth is down so prices are up but
the attack on the ability to borrow
money for companies that want to drill
or want to be you know exploring for oil
to the extent that they can it's it can
be devastating how are you going to
fight back on on that issue well unlike
Beto I do support the oil and gas
industry Texas ranks number one in the
United States for oil and gas production
and we will continue to do so but let me
explain to you what we're doing to fight
back because what we're doing to fight
back is last session I signed a law that
exists in Texas now where we are
fighting back against any business like
black rock or USB or UBS or any of these
banking companies that discriminate
against oil and gas companies and do not
lend them money we are blackballing them
they're already starting to dry up the
money into these companies we're
blackballing them from doing business in
the state of Texas they cannot
participate in any funding how about the
Pension funds in this state we're
blackballing all of these guys are you
cutting them off in the Pension funds
Pension funds okay
that's good
Governor I can't wait to talk to you
after your reelection but
congratulations for everything you've
done in this state and everyone get out
and vote for Greg Abbott thank you so
much thank you Laura hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else